hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor
today we're going to cover a topic that
i personally find
very very interesting and that is
membrane asymmetry
and sightedness so first we'll talk
about
what that means what do we mean when we
say membrane asymmetry and membrane
sightedness
and then we're going to talk about how
that sightedness
comes to be the cellular processes that
create
the different insides and outsides of
membranes
so first let's start by addressing the
fact that biological membranes
they are made up of a lipid bilayer a
drawn one here
so lipid bilayer meaning that you've got
some
phospholipids uh and there's two layers
there's the
outer layer right here that's mainly red
and blue
and the inner layer right here that's
mainly um green and purple
and each one of these things is a
phospholipid so you've got the
phospholipid heads
that's the phosphate head head groups
and then the lipid
tails so phosphate head groups lipid
tails in the middle
so you've got the um the hydrophilic
character on the outside
of each leaflet and the hydrophobic
character on the inside where the tails
are
so these lipid bilayers are
asymmetric
what does this mean it means they are
composed of two leaflets that have
different compositions so you have
different types
of phospholipids on the outer leaflet
and different types of phospholipids on
the inner
leaflet so that's what we mean by the
asymmetry there
and so i'm going to point out a few
features here i've drawn some
transmembrane proteins
right here we have a co-transporter
that's transporting
protons and glucose into the cell we've
also got some peripheral proteins down
here of course those are ones that are
associated with the membrane but don't
go all the way through it like the
transmembrane proteins do
peripheral proteins they are usually on
the cytosolic side
i'll write that right here cytosolic
that's the basically the inside besides
touching the
cytoplasm or the cytosol and then
we have some glyco appendages these are
basically
branched sugar chains that can be
attached to either
membrane proteins or to phospholipids
themselves
these are typically on the outer or
extracellular leaflet
i've already written outer over here i'm
going to put extracellular now in
parentheses
so um okay so we're talking about the
different compositions
we've got the different types of
phospholipids that are present on one
leaflet versus another
the fact that peripheral proteins are
usually on the inside
the fact that we've got the glucose the
sugar basically
sugar chains on the outside um also you
know these
transmembrane proteins they'll have an
outside like an extra cellular facing
domain and an intracellular facing
domain so so what it
what this transmembrane protein looks
like down here is different from what it
looks like up here
and so this is really critical to the
functioning of the membrane in order for
the membrane to
carry out its roles for the membrane
proteins to carry out
their roles everything has to be in
there in the correct orientation
with the correct things facing outward
and the correct things facing inward
now let's talk about how how dynamic
this is we know that
when we talk about the the plasma
membrane about biological membranes in
general
you often hear them referred to as like
um fluid mosaics so the fluid mosaic
model is maybe something that you've
heard of before
and here you know the fluidity means
that these things are very dynamic you
can have things that are moving around
in the membrane these phospholipids are
moving
with respect to each other they can be
rotating
you know this one right here can move
over here and this one can move over
here
and so there's a lot of movement in
these membranes and so we're going to
talk now about three different kinds of
movement
the first is lateral diffusion
so lateral diffusion is moving
within one leaflet so a phospholipid or
a protein
that is moving um
you know basically from here to here or
from here to here or from here to here
and so that's the lateral diffusion
there's also
rotation which refers to the fact that
these
these phospholipids and these bilayers
you know
they um they're generally able to rotate
so they can kind of
spin around like this marker is doing
spin around in place that's the rotation
so the lateral diffusion and the
rotation those things happen quite
frequently
what is more rare is what we call
transverse diffusion
so the transverse diffusion is movement
from one leaflet to another so we're
talking about
like a red one moving down here to be
with the purple and green ones
or a purple or green one moving from
this leaflet up to this leaflet where
mainly the red and blue ones are that's
the transverse diffusion
it does happen but it requires
enzymes these are known as flip faces
and flop bases and we'll talk more about
those in a second
but this allows them to travel from one
leaflet to another leaflet
now within these leaflets the reason
that i've drawn red and blue
phospholipids on the in the outer
leaflet
and green and purple and the inner
leaflet is because
we do see certain phospholipids that are
predominantly in the outer leaflet
and certain phospholipids that are
predominantly in the inner leaflet and
so i have those listed down here
in the outer leaflet that's the
extracellular leaflet
we typically see sphingomyelin
phosphatidylcholine
various glycolipids the glycolipids
right here are the ones that have the
sugar
uh chains the sugar chains attached to
them
so and make sure you see the word here
predominantly that means there's
a lot of sphingomyelin up here a lot of
phosphatidylcholine up here
various types of glycolipids up here
but sometimes you know some of these
things can
can flip into the inner leaflet
sometimes things from the inner leaflet
can
you know can do that transverse uh
diffusion
into the outer leaflet and so it is
predominantly we're talking about kind
of the big picture here also you should
realize that
different kinds of cells and different
kinds of organisms
are going to have different types of
phospholipids present in different
ratios in different places and so we're
kind of speaking about just like
predominantly here and then
now that we have talked about the outer
leaflet phospholipids we'll now talk
about the inner leaflet phospholipids
where i have
green and purple drawn on the board this
is predominantly
again predominantly not 100 but
predominantly
phosphatidyl ethanolamine
phosphatidylserine
phosphatidylinositol these are all just
different kinds of
phospholipids now you might be saying
why
why why have phosphatidylserine
mainly in the inner leaflet and single
myelin
mainly in the outer leaflet well it's
because these
um these phospholipids the different
types of phospholipids they
serve different purposes they do
different jobs and i have a few of those
listed here
in the outer leaflet the outer leaflet
so the the one that's drawn on top
right here that's the extracellular
portion of the bilayer
that functions in cell attachment in
cell spreading and cell migration
whereas the inner leaflet the cytosolic
side
of the membrane it modulates the actin
cytoskeleton it modulates certain ion
channels
and so these different kinds of
phospholipids
they play different roles and you know
and that's why we see some mainly in one
leaflet and some mainly in another
leaflet
so now let's talk about how do we build
this
how do we build the asymmetry how do
cells
make sure that the right uh
phospholipids
get on in one leaflet versus another
leaflet
and a lot of that has to do with the
endoplasmic
reticulum and the golgi apparatus so
here i have um some a drawing
of a vesicle that is engaged in
exocytosis
and those are probably things that you
are familiar with from studying the cell
you've got vesicles they
will move things from one place to
another in the cell
also carry things outside the cell
through exocytosis
but this is also how membranes are
replenished which i think is something
students often forget
and and should remember because it's
cool right
so right here we've got the plasma
membrane and i've drawn it in kind of
this
dark purple brown color so we've got the
intracellular
side of the membrane and the
extracellular or the outside
side of the membrane and what happens
when a vesicle
let me write that right here this is a
vesicle
so this vesicle is carrying a few
different things it's carrying some
transmembrane proteins
that are embedded in its membrane i've
drawn those in blue
and it's also carrying some things i've
drawn some purple circles in there
that's just meant to be um like proteins
and small
molecules that are being um
that are being sent out of the cell they
could be signaling compounds
they could be waste products whoops
i don't usually do that uh
so just something that the cell is
wanting
to leave wanting to leave this out
and so when this vesicle is constructed
it's constructed in a very specific way
because you see this right here i'm
going to draw a big star
this is important the inside
of the endoplasmic reticulum and the
inside of the golgi apparatus that i
don't have drawn here that you can
google some images
the in the inner membranes of those
organelles
and the inner membrane of the vesicle
that's drawn here in red
that is continuous with the outside
of the plasma membrane so i'm going to
say that again
the endoplasmic reticulum and the
golgi apparatus and the vesicles that
connect them
and the vesicles that they are sending
out of the cell the inner leaflets
of all of those are continuous
with the outside of the plasma membrane
what does that mean well look at this
vesicle the
inner membrane the inner the inner
leaflet of the membrane
of the lipid bilayer is drawn in red and
here's the exocytosis happening
i'll label that here as well
and where does that inner leaflet of the
membrane go
look here it winds up on the outside of
the cell
so here we have the cytoplasm inside
and we have the extracellular matrix i'm
just going to write ecm
the extracellular makes tricks outside
and where is the red
the red goes from being the inner
leaflet here
to the outer leaflet of the plasma
membrane
so that means that the asymmetrical
distribution making sure that you get
you know the extracellular domains um
on in in the correct leaflet and you get
the the correct phospholipids on the
correct sides and the correct inner and
outer leaflets
that is all done by the endoplasmic
reticulum
and the golgi apparatus i'm going to
label those with some initials so er
for endoplasmic reticulum and ga
for golgi apparatus when they are
building
new membrane and when they are getting
things um sorted and processed getting
everything in the correct orientation
that's being done by the er and the
golgi and they are aided
by two enzymes i've already mentioned
called flip basins
and flop bases and no i'm not making
those up
so enzymes they have cute names i know
flip bases
and flop bases and i'm going to have
another separate video on the specific
work of flip bases and flop bases and
you can check those out
but they are responsible for getting the
right
uh phospholipids in the outer
versus the inner leaflet and in order
for them to be on the outer leaflet of
the plasma membrane
they've got to get them to the inner
leaflet of a vesicle
to get them to the inner leaflet of the
plasma membrane they've got to get them
to the
outer leaflet of the vesicle that's
shown here in green see the outside of
the vesicle
ends up being the inside the inner
leaflet
of the i'm going to write pm here for
plasma membrane
and then also take a look at the protein
orientation
so these receptors right here they are
embedded within the vesicle membrane
um this is happening way back at the
endoplasmic reticulum
they are these um transmembrane proteins
receptor proteins
they are embedded in such a way that
their extracellular domains
the ones that are going to be sticking
out of the cell
have to actually be pointing toward the
inside of the vesicle again because the
inside of the vesicle is continuous with
the outside of the plasma membrane
so look what happens when you have the
exocytosis happening you eventually get
what was pointed inside the vesicle
is now pointing outside of the cell
where they can then
you know receive their ligands i'm just
going to draw some basic ligands here
and then have the signaling cascades in
the cell that happen
when these receptors receive their
ligands and then before we conclude one
last thing to point out
this symmetry is very important the
cells work
hard to maintain the asymmetry to build
it in the first place
and then to maintain it and so loss of
asymmetry
if you see a cell that is no longer
having like a distinct outer leaflet and
a distinct inner leaflet but having kind
of the same ratios
of the foss of the different kinds of
phospholipids in both the outer and
inner leaflet that's actually an early
indicator
of apoptosis or
program cell death so that is an
unhealthy cell
that is beginning apoptosis it's
beginning apoptosis it is getting ready
to basically self-destruct
and so it's no longer putting a lot of
energy
into keeping that membrane asymmetry to
be able to carry out
the functions that those different
leaflets carry out
so if you're interested in learning more
about this i'm going to have some videos
made soon over flip faces and flop bases
also over
a different kind of enzyme that
impacts the asymmetry of membranes that
are called scram laces
so i will put links to those in the
description and
thank you very much for watching biology
professor see you next time